first of all I just want to say
congratulations on season five I then
watched the first Eight Episodes before
this interview and I think it might be
the best season yet
I I was floored by this season
absolutely floored
it's successful oh thank you I I as I
was reading this scripts I was like
I mean I've been with it for five years
and I was stunned
I said wait a minute what
I I you know for the writers I mean to
say
and of course directors yeah
yeah I was talking about it with my mom
and I was like this is the season that
they need to win everything this is just
like a phenomenal season isn't that
lovely thank you honey thank you and I
was curious to know like as a viewer is
very emotional
most tackling some of these really
difficult scenes what is it like for you
and do you find yourself needing to
decompress after the day well it's
always challenging a complex
well-written character always is and
that's part of the joy isn't it uh and
so
just to come prepared and open and ready
uh to jump in and to know you don't have
all the answers a first time round
um
it's a phenomenal experience and
you know the thing is for actors we
don't take the consequences home with us
you know what I mean
everybody's nobody's hurt
and so the joy is it's make believe for
us
but doesn't make it easier for the
viewer to watch God knows but that's
what allows us to jump in without any
worry
and by the end of the day you're tired
man you know you're like thank you Lydia
thank you very much see you tomorrow
have a good night because I'm going home
and having a beverage and putting my
feet up you know it's something it's
something like that talking about
consequences um episode two definitely
has a pretty big twist at the end of it
um in terms of Janine and Esther
um and Aunt Lydia has always had this
really complex relationship with Janine
and so what's going through her mind can
you tease a little bit of that
the thing that's part of the joy that
Lydia is beginning to experience and the
profound what's happening is that she
loves that girl she loves that girl as
her own
and
Lydia has so many defenses and so much
protection so much armor travels a very
narrow road but when you have such
feelings
love in particular
those walls aren't going to stay hooked
it's just not how we're built as human
beings
love is far more powerful
than fear if we allow it to take
its place
and so I think it's throwing Lydia
because she's seeing things differently
now and she's seeing what's going on
no
um speaking of later in the season uh
aware of what's really going on here not
what she thought or not what she was
willing to really look at and say hey is
this all right I don't know is this in
their best interest
you know she's just starting to
look at the truth I've seen those
moments kind of coming through over the
course of the past five years Lydia's
kind of gotten to that point where she
almost wants to make a change but she
shies away from it
um do you do you have like a
a moment for her this season that feels
like a turning point that in the script
when you're working with it that you're
like this is where things are shifting a
little bit more extreme for her this
time
the changes are they more extreme is
that you're just saying well I think
there's an abruptness to them but
because as the walls I'm trying to think
of a better a better metaphor if you
will uh as as the protection
and the defenses are are beginning to
not hold up
she has two choices she can put the
armor back up
and say I don't know what that does
nonsense
I I I I I I I I'm being way too soft on
her and uh I'm I'm going this is this is
or you can just leave the armor down
and I think that is the choice that
Lydia makes
uh to her credit looking ahead this is a
spoiler question feel free to answer I'm
going to hold it until we get to that
episode but looking ahead to what
happens with Putnam and seeing Lydia
really take that stand and then seeing
that there are actually consequences to
the actions of the meta Gilead what was
it like for you getting to see that
script and then getting to play it out
on set that day because it's such a
powerful like seeing him hanging there
is such a powerful moment well I think
thank you for saying his name I had
forgotten it was Putnam coming up with
other names for him but you know
punishment an end to that behavior
a consequence uh
would Lydia have hung him on the wall uh
as she's beginning to change
or would she have put him in prison for
life we're here to sit with himself
because you know you leave the world and
you leave the pain behind you know what
I'm saying so and I think Lydia also
realized that Lawrence
did it for a number of reasons oh isn't
this convenient command of Arts you look
like you know Mr righteous setting the
values back into place protecting them
and getting rid of the man who was
opposed
a little bit to what your plans were who
could have been a problem in future now
he's gone wow I think she sees it all
and uh you know she has to work with
Lawrence because she doesn't she's a
woman she gets it but they need each
other
so it's a very
uh interesting relationship that way
yeah consequence of the actions are such
an interesting thing that's played with
in handmaid's tale and also like there's
10 sense of like Redemption and like
what happens to these people as Gilead
continues to evolve do you think there's
a place of redemption for Lydia she's
such a character that like you don't
want to fully hate that she does things
that are so horrible to see on screen
but is there a place where she could be
redeemed as Gilead continues to evolve I
think so I mean I would I would I think
the journey will continue in the
handmaid's tale and it will certainly
continue into the Testaments
um and there's the answer to that
question
um but yes I think she's capable of it
thank you so much thank you honey thank
you Maggie a pleasure speaking with you